hello everyone today I want to do a
video to thank a friend of mine Darrell
E use for all the hard work that he puts
into his channel now I had the good
fortune to be on Darrell's channel not
too long ago link up the video here
talking about how to get speaking and
get consumed youtube channel and daryl
is an expert on video marketing and
online marketing he has a really popular
YouTube channel and it's one of the
handful of channels that I subscribe to
and watch every single video religiously
and so Darrell just wanted to thank you
for all the hard work that you put into
your channel all the love that you give
us for educating us and teaching us to
be better and I also gathered some of
your loyal fans and followers and
viewers they wanted to share their own
message for you as well so here we go
Darrell dude I have so much to thank you
for one is your friendship like thank
you so much for just being available to
me I really appreciate our phone calls
the text messages and just kind of being
available like hey whatever you need to
him I'm there for you and I really
honestly I really do thank you for that
and appreciate that also too just for
your ongoing support whether it's just
through collaborations or especially
like last year at VidCon you took a lot
of time to sit down with me he didn't
have to but you did just because I can
tell it you really care about people and
I could I really felt that you sat down
he gave me you know a lot of great
business advice and ideas just to help
me with what I'm doing here on video
creators and understand like the
business side of all this I really do
appreciate that and like I said I can
totally tell that you are someone who
definitely cares about people and wants
to invest into people and you care about
that farm are more than anything else so
if I thank you for being at that example
for me and for countless other youtubers
here on this platform hi Darrell just a
quick thank you for all the help you
gave me with my channel and all the
wonderful help you have given to all of
the YouTube creator community out here
oh we're so fortunate to have somebody
who shares his talent and knowledge so
freely and I know you really helped me
move the needle on my channel and you've
helped so many so I just want to say
thank you for for being you happy
crafting I come from the Marine Corps
background when I retired from the
Marine Corps so when it comes to you too
I had zero experience so use channel has
been critical to my channel and i watch
your videos you know i'm commenting all
your videos and everything that you stay
up pretty much running to my channel and
i apply that into my channel so i really
appreciate your support I really
appreciate your videos and I really
appreciate all your help thank you so
much and God bless you hello there East
just want to say cook thanks to all the
support you've been doing for YouTube
beginners and you're just one of the
best of the best YouTube expert out
there and thanks a lot there is your
face makes my face smile every time I
see you thank you thank you thank you so
much for all that you do for all the
youtubers just like me this is tamara
wheat in nebraska and i will talk to you
soon bye bye since starting my channel
over a year ago I've been very dedicated
in growing it don't leaves has provided
me with information the tips and
inspiration to make that happen I'd like
to say a big thank you to dabble and
keep making your awesome videos jeez
hello Darryl I run the total OS today
technology channel here on YouTube my
friends call me toss I just wanted to
say that I think your channel is totally
cool but not as cool as my shades just
kidding keep up the good work Darryl bye
hi Darryl chilly here with a big thanks
for all you do for all of us said if
only I could find the little cub to
speed this up to go twice as fast I
could tell everybody about everything
that you've done for us but in lieu of
being able to find a little girl I will
merely say this video is for you for all
you do thank you I there were easy Steve
sjw here from the Netherlands and yeah I
just want to thank you for all the
support and all the spices you gave to
us and you're also
I hope your channel is gonna get so big
and i got i hope you gonna help some
more people together channel growing and
yeah you're just awesome dude so yeah
peace out hey there Darrell I think you
and your channel in your videos are
great and I think it's awesome you
dedicate your own time to try to help
other Creators even though the little
ones like myself to grow and fulfill
their dreams YouTube is my absolute
dream and it is awesome to see a channel
i can rely on to get some awesome
information and awesome tricks to make
my dream you know come true your videos
and channel help all of us reach for the
digital YouTube stars so thank you for
that thank you doing what you do hey
this is Joseph want to thank once again
Darrell for all that you do
congratulations on reaching 100,000
subscribers and thank you so much for
providing this the good information it's
also entertaining keep it up thanks hey
Donald I just like sebek thank you for
all the context of released in the past
year I have grown wait about and I feel
more confident with the videos I
produced and send out people YouTube I'd
like to thank you for all your hard work
and well thanks about it I'll be seeing
more of your content and take care thank
you Darrell for all the time and effort
you put into helping us succeed on
YouTube not only with all the practical
tips and tricks and all the tutorials
but also with all the motivation that
you gave in your various for that I'm
very grateful to be one of your many
subscribers almost remember that nothing
is absolute anything is possible keep on
going and I let support you hi Darrell
its Patti Rockstar mom and at 71 years
old you know that I claim to be the
oldest person actually doing videos here
on YouTube many many years ago Darrell I
learned something that continues to
serve me even today and that is when we
help other people to achieve their goals
and their dreams we also achieve hours
and that's what you do here on YouTube
Darrell you're helping all of us to
achieve our goals in our dreams and
there is no doubt in my mind that that's
the reason for your tremendous success
your clients are so lucky to have you as
their coach and their mentor those of us
here on YouTube are so lucky to have you
giving us tips and tricks and ways not
only to grow our channels but to produce
better content I think Darrell that the
reason that so many of us who truly put
your tips into action are successful is
because we know that you truly care
found us I hope you're having a
wonderful day I'll see you soon bye bye
hey Darryl Reeves my name is Patrick
Dipple and I run a blog here on YouTube
about being a nursing school and I just
want to say thank you so much for all
that helpful tips and advice you've
given me I've learned a lot from your
channel about minute watch time and how
to tag my videos and just all of your
videos and your personality are just so
great and helpful so anyway Evan
Carmichael sent me I just wanted to say
thank you hey Darryl this is nick i just
want to say thank you for giving us the
information that you gave us on your
channel to help us grow our channel help
us know more about YouTube and how to
make all of our stuff better and I want
to say thank you for being cool enough
to reach out to the people that watch
your videos subscribe keep up the good
work man thank you what's up Darrell is
I just want to thank you for all the
valley got you give and that some of the
things that you contribute to the
YouTube society and how you built your
own channel and some of the things that
I've learned from you and some of the
things I can take and take and go and
some things I still got work on my
channel but overall you have created
this journey for me and now it's my time
to say thank you and I appreciate
everything that you do in your own
channel about my own channel and from
there i'll see you thank you very very
much Darrell you've helped my channel
and myself out very very much and I'm
sure other creators will join me in
thanking you for all the hard work
you've done obviously you can see the
iron from the gaming community so I'm
yeah thank you very much from the gaming
community and I'm yeah be sure to keep
up the good work you are such a great
guy hey Darrell ease this video is for
you I just wanted to tell you how
awesome you are I want to thank you for
helping me with my channel and being
very supportive of me and my channel
you've helped millions of people and I
just want to thank you for that for
everybody in the YouTube community and
please keep up the good work and you're
an inspiration to us all and
you're awesome bro you've got so much
information out there it's like a
library and you're the number one person
that I can trust or I feel like you're
knowledgeable thank you and goodbye and
arrow this is david from YouTube's
number one swimming pool channel just
wanted to say thank you for all your
great videos and all your tipsy you all
for everyone I've learned a lot from
watching you over the last year or so
keep up the good work thanks a lot again
hey guys XP she ate and I want to thank
Dallas always helping use you for for
mail annotations and banner so I just
want to find out dailies to youtube so
thank you hey Darrell I just want to pop
on and tell you how much I appreciate
all the knowledge and information that
you share it truly does mean a lot so
thank you so there are things again for
all the love that you put into the
channel and for helping us grow our
businesses online for those of you who
haven't heard of daryl is yet you can go
check out his channel i'll put the link
below and continue to believe thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon what I want to do what did I want
to do to do bump a bump a bump a bump up
up up up up I forgot what I was saying
do to do to do okay